but before I show you an actual phase
diagram I want to just take a moment and
try to explain to you how this can be
and we're going to do this by just
drawing little pictures and and and just
thinking to ourselves how could you
imagine packing and fats together so
remember I told you that triglycerides
and this is really a general fact for
all fats but triglycerides actually
consist of these two arms with this one
long arm that's stuck to it and if we
start to think to ourselves just draw on
a little doodle pad you know how is it
that we're gonna stack these things
together there are really at least two
ways that you can do it so one is that
what you could imagine doing is taking
the long arm and stacking it in such a
way like it's shown in this picture with
a long arm is actually that is the
single arm is actually adjacent to the
double arms in the layer before it so
this picture is what's called the double
chain packing what you see is that the
long arm is not of one molecule is on
top of the double arm on the other and
they basically flip back and forth from
layer to layer which gives rise to the
packing so there's also another logical
possibility which is what people call
the triple chain packing in which what
you do is you put the the two double
arms on top of each other and you put
the single arms on top of each other so
you basically align the things so that
the the single arms are like this and
the double arms are like this and that's
shown in this picture and when you do
that that's called the triple chain
packing and that's a different way of
packing right the triglycerides now
these two different packings you know
have different energies right it might
be more sticky to do double chain or
more sticky to do triple chain and
whether it is what is true actually
really depends on the detail of the fats
I mean so for example if you could just
imagine as a thought experiment if you
had a saturated fat in the single chain
then the saturated fats might like the
the single chains might like to stack
together very well right um you know
whereas if it were if the unsaturated
fats were in the chains then they're
sort of harder to stick and then the of
course the heads with the two double
chains that could be a different packing
stacking interaction altogether and it
really as you can see from listening to
me it gets a bit complicated to figure
out just from thinking about it alone
what the different stacking behavior is
and this is really something which is an
experimental subject it can be
empirically determined by studying the
phases of fats
and by looking under the microscope
under a very powerful microscope to find
out you know how the molecules are
stacked okay so without his background I
now want to show you the phase diagram
of chocolate and I'm going to try to
relate this to what I just said so this
is the phase diagram of chocolate so
chocolate has as I said six crystalline
phases that vary in temperature from 18
degrees to 36 degrees so the lowest
phase which people call phase one
cleverly has a melting temperature of
about eighteen degrees
the second phase which people call phase
two is about 22 degrees and then there
are other phases those phase four which
is 34 degrees in Phase six which is 36
degrees and so on and so forth and these
are the six different phases so what do
I mean by different phase what I mean is
well for one thing it melts at a
different temperature it just you know
comes apart if you made the material out
of only that phase and you heated it up
to the melting temperature then it would
come apart at that temperature so and I
also mean that if you were to look at
the structure that is the way the
molecules are packed they are actually
different in each of these different
phases which is the reason that it melts
right at different positions now what's
interesting about these numbers if you
just think about my little experiment
with my piece of chocolate a little
while ago is that if you remember that
body temperature right that is your
mouth is 37 degrees and your hand is
let's say it's 28 degrees or something
if you want to find a material out of
this phase diagram which melts doesn't
melt in your hand but melts in your
mouth you can see the really the only
options you've got even from the get-go
our phase is five and six the the two
highest phases may be phase four it's
close to the border line but phases five
and six are really what you have and in
fact it turns out that five and six are
the are the ones that and in particular
phase five is the phase that you need to
hit in order to make the chocolate that
you know and love and that we saw so
spectacularly illustrated by Enric now
if you think about preparations you can
immediately see from just looking at
this diagram and thinking about how it
is you're ever going to do this why it
is so hard for the home chef or for
somebody who's inexperienced like me to
make chocolate in their kitchen it's
because you somehow have to basically
get the cocoa butter which you know you
can buy cocoa butter where you can just
take chocolate and melt that like you
know put it very high temp
and you will basically get for yourself
a mix of cocoa butter and but then the
question is how would you get it - only
crystallize in the phase at phase five
which is what you want
I mean clearly if you if you cool it to
a low temperature like 22 degrees then
you know it can it can cool into all of
these different phases so what you know
so what are you supposed to do - to make
this happen and the the complexities of
making chocolate are all associated with
this issue